the idea was in order to tell a story
that takes place 40 years later you have
to go to the original story and then
jump it forward 40 years and I think
that was the brilliance of just their
concept new in theaters this weekend
Halloween the 40 year later sequel to
the original 1978 Halloween are you
brave enough this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
but gosh yeah Saturday Night Live's Mike
Myers returns to the big screen this
weekend in Halloween Mike Myers Michael
Myers Michael have been nice to hear
before Michael Myers not Mike Myers
returns to the big screen this weekend
in technically the 11th installment of
the Halloween franchise but
chronologically the sequel to the
original 1978 John Carpenter masterpiece
I mean your grandmother is Laurie Strode
she was almost murdered wasn't it her
brother who murdered all those
babysitters yeah it was not her brother
that's the main that people made up
which will also technically be the fifth
iteration of the Halloween franchise
timeline if you haven't seen the other
ten this might seem confusing but all
you need to know is this version will
definitely keep you on the edge of your
seat as Laurie Strode seeks justice do
you know that I pray every night that he
would escape hey Belle did you do that
for so I can kill him
this movie is for you if you're a fan of
any of the previous Halloween movies
you're looking to get your Halloween
season slasher fix or do you love Austin
Powers sorry baby
that is your weekend ticket what's your
favorite Halloween franchise movie and
check back next week for eight less
slasher each choice of Rowan Atkinson's
antics and a side of submarine drama
[Music]